und beispielsweise das thema pflege als
auch das thema fachkräfte einwanderungs
und asylpolitik sind auch aufgenommen
worden in ihrer stellungnahme von sahra
wagenknecht
einer der beiden vorsitzenden der
linksfraktion und das ganze war auch
noch deshalb besonders interessant weil
das ganze auch noch mit einer personalie
verbunden gewesen ist denn eigentlich
wollte sarah wagenknecht ja zu beginn
der parlamentarischen sommerpause also
ende des monats ihr amt niederlegen sind
rücktritt hat sie mitte märz angekündigt
aber nun geht alles noch ein klein wenig
länger als das wir im gehören jetzt in
der stellungnahme von sahra wagenknecht
ersparen hat ja heute die ergebnisse der
konzertierten aktion pflege vorgestellt
dann muss man zunächst einmal sagen es
ist ja eine gute sache dass sich
immerhin drei ministerien mit diesem
drängenden thema der katastrophalen
zustände in vielen pflegeheimen in
deutschland beschäftigt haben das
immerhin auch bestimmte probleme
aufgeworfen wurden die allerdings auch
vorher bekannt waren und ja nun
eingängig in der debatte sind miese
löhne ein völlig über eine völlige
überforderung der pflegekräfte durch
einen mangelnden pflegeschlüssel wenn
man sich allerdings die ergebnisse
anguckt dann muss man wirklich sagen
also da kreiste wieder mal ein berg und
es war noch nicht mal eine maus sind gut
klingende absichtserklärungen aber ich
finde gerade ein solches problem wie das
der pflege es braucht nicht
absichtserklärungen die hören wir seit
vielen jahren sondern es braucht ganz
konkrete veränderungen
es braucht ganz konkrete politische
entscheidungen die dazu führen dass
pflegekräfte deutlich höher bezahlt
werden weil solange das nicht der fall
ist wird man auch das problem nicht
lösen dass sich immer weniger junge
menschen für diesen wichtigen beruf
entscheiden
es braucht ganz konkrete entscheidungen
zu einem pflegeschlüssel also zu einem
personalschlüssel in den pflegeheimen
die zustände sind wirklich unerträglich
wenn man mit pflegerinnen und pflegern
spricht wo teilweise dann sogar
auszubildende alleine für zwölf alte
menschen zuständig
es sind wo sie zehn minuten haben um
sich mit den menschen zu befassen
das sind unerträglich und inhumane
zustände und daran wirklich etwas zu
ändern das wäre eigentlich die aufgabe
der politik dafür sind die ergebnisse
allerdings viel zu mager und ich muss
auch sagen ein ganz zentrales problem
spielte überhaupt keine rolle in der
gesamten debatte seitens der regierung
und das ist das problem der zunehmenden
kommerzialisierung der pflege weil dass
sich die zustände in vielen pflegeheimen
zuspitzen das ist wenig personal gibt
das ist schlecht bezahlt wird
das hat ja nicht zuletzt auch damit zu
tun dass viele pflegeheime heute vor
allem eine aufgabe haben nämlich profit
zu erwirtschaften weil große hedgefonds
finanzinvestoren sich in seniorenheime
einkaufen und dort einen richtigen
reibach machen und ich finde dieses
problem muss endlich adressiert werden
es kann nicht wahr sein dass die pflege
alter menschen zu einem objekt für
renditemaximierung wird diese bereich da
geht es darum menschen würde da geht es
darum dass alte menschen ihren
lebensabend genießen können die große
koalition weiß selbst dass ihr
lebensfaden abläuft und die offenbar
nicht mehr viel zeit hat deswegen wird
da eine gewisse hektik an den tag gelegt
wir werden wohl diese woche dass
fachkräfte einwanderungsgesetz und das
andere gesetz zudem viele herabgesetzt
sagen beschliessen im parlament oder
zumindest wird es dort in einem
schnellverfahren vorgelegt werden
teilweise sogar ohne debatte bei zwei so
grundlegenden gesetzen ist das schon ein
riesiges problem und ich finde gerade
beim fachkräfte einwanderungsgesetz mir
ist uns ist natürlich bewusst dass es da
massive forderungen der wirtschaft gibt
und man hier auch wünschen der
wirtschaft entgegen kommt indem man
dieses gesetz jetzt durchsetzt
allerdings ist es zwar unstrittig dass
es in deutschland in bestimmten
bereichen einen pflege nur einen
personalnotstand gibt dass es
fachkräftemangel gibt das kann man in
bestimmten bereichen nicht bestreiten
aber zu glauben dass wir dieses problem
durch forcierte einwanderung lösen ist
natürlich ein irrglaube denn wir müssen
ja mal über die ursachen reden vielfach
sind das berufe in denen die löhne sich
sehr schlecht entwickelt haben in dem
sich junge menschen einfach nicht mehr
ausbilden lassen
also es wäre auch eine andere
möglichkeit einfach wieder bessere löhne
zu zahlen und dort auch berufe wieder
attraktiv zu machen
wenn wir über fachkräftemangel reden
müssen wir über die uhr duale ausbildung
reden das war ja lange zeit wirklich
eine einer der großen vorzüge die
deutschland hatte dass die duale
ausbildung auch jenseits des
akademischen bereichs für attraktive
berufsbilder geschaffen hat heutzutage
haben sich gerade große unternehmen
immer mehr aus der dualen ausbildung
zurückgezogen und damit natürlich ist
das problem dass nicht mehr genug
ausgebildet wird währenddessen die idee
also wir holen uns aus ärmeren ländern
ausgebildete fachkräfte ist natürlich
diesen ländern gegenüber in höchsten
maße unsolidarisch man kann sogar sagen
zynisch weil gerade arme länder haben
natürlich viel mehr probleme sich mit
fachkräften also ihre fachkräfte
auszubilden und ein land wie deutschland
sollte schon in der lage sein das auf
eigene rechnung zu leisten statt arme
länder noch ärmer zu machen weil so
schafft man fluchtursachen so hilft man
nicht dass in anderen teilen der welt
ein mindestmaß an wohlstand und
wirtschaftliche entwicklung entsteht und
stattfindet ich habe immer gesagt dass
ich mir gewünscht hätte und dass ich mir
wünsche dass wir im juni eine neuwahl an
der fraktionsspitze machen
das war eigentlich auch der plan wir
haben jetzt allerdings zur kenntnis
nehmen müssen dass es einerseits eine
politische landschaft gibt wo man nicht
so genau weiß was sich in den nächsten
wochen und monaten ereignet und das
zweite war dass es ja auch sehr partei
heraus massive wünsche gab an die
fraktionen es gab ein brief der
ostdeutschen landesvorsitzenden jetzt
keine personelle neuaufstellung
vorzunehmen sondern das zu verschieben
und deswegen habe ich mich dann quasi
auch diesen wunsch gebeugt das ist jetzt
nicht mein traum gewesen aber das werden
wir jetzt eben so machen ich hatte immer
erklärt ich mache es bis zum ende meiner
wahlperiode und gut strenggenommen ende
die eben erst im herbst